dans une vidéo récente je vous ai
présenté un des concepts central des
sciences sociales en général ou de la
sociologie en particulier le fait social
dans cette vidéo j'avais expliqué
comment emile durkheim défini ce fait
social
si cette vidéo permet de bien comprendre
la construction de cet objet d'étude
elle ne permet pas à l'élève ou à
l'étudiant de savoir concrètement ce
qu'est un fait social et comment le
distinguer dans la réalité
dans cette vidéo je propose aux élèves
et aux étudiants quelques trucs qui leur
permettront de bien identifier les faits
sociaux qu'ils souhaitent travailler
la première chose à faire est de bien
savoir si on a affaire à quelque chose
qui est social pour ce faire il suffit
de se demander si les relations sociales
sont bien indispensable à l'existence du
fait que l'on souhaite analyser fialaire
les relations sociales
est ce qu'elle fait est juste quelques
jours par exemple l'addiction aux
réseaux sociaux existent toujours
si je supprime les relations sociales en
effet la personne pourra continuer à
être addict aux réseaux sociaux
même si elle n'a aucun contact avec les
personnes sur ces réseaux sociaux
elle peut faire mille et une choses sur
le réseau social donc l'addiction aux
réseaux sociaux n'est pas un fait social
car le social n'est pas indispensable à
l'existence de ce fait de même
étudier le manque de sommeil chez les
jeunes n'apparaît pas directement comme
un fait social
on pourrait très bien supprimer les
relations sociales entre les jeunes et
il pourrait toujours manquer de sommeil
par conte l'influencent des discussions
sur les réseaux sociaux peut jouer sur
le manque de sommeil des jeunes est donc
là ça devient un fait social puisque si
j'enlève les relations sociales
les jeunes ne discute plus entre eux et
donc le fait n'existe plus cette manière
de faire permet dans un premier temps
d'écarter un certain nombre de faits qui
ne sont pas des faits sociaux
cependant il faut éviter l' analyse trop
simpliste et si on appliquait de manière
un peu trop automatique cette méthode on
en viendrait à considérer le suicide
comme quelque chose qui n'est pas social
or emile durkheim nous montre que le
suicide est un fait social pour y
arriver il associe une variable
indépendante elle même très social qui
va expliquer le suicide qui nous
apparaît comme un fait qui ne serait pas
social au départ et dans sa célèbre
étude du suicide
il analyse le fils need à partir de la
cohésion sociale
et c'est cette construction théorique
qui fait du suicide un fait social vous
l'aurez compris la façon de construire
le fait social ou de le présenter fait
qu'il est plus ou moins social
une autre manière de bien identifier un
fait social et de prendre en compte sa
récurrents c'est-à-dire le nombre de
fois que le fai se produit dans le temps
et dans l'espace
il doit se reproduire à plusieurs
endroits à plusieurs moments par exemple
la baffe que michel a donné à son fils
thomas n'est pas un fait social car il
s'agit d'un acte isolé et peut-être même
tout à fait exceptionnel michel est
quelqu'un de bien qui ne frappe jamais
ses enfants
par contre les maltraitances familiale
se reproduisent dans plusieurs familles
à différentes époques et à différents
endroits il s'agit donc bien d'un fait
social de l'abstraction est très
importante quand il s'agit de définir un
fait social pour rappel l'abstraction
c'est juste la capacité d'imaginer un
fait générale et abstraite c'est à dire
qu'il n'est pas directement ancré dans
la réalité bien souvent l'identification
d'un fait social passe par l'utilisation
d'un vocabulaire précis et de définition
bien posé il est donc très important de
bien prendre son temps de s'asseoir et
de réfléchir avant de se prononcer comme
à chaque fois en sciences sociales
[Musique]
à
pourquoi